hello believe nation I started the
mentor me series with the goal to learn
from people who've done a lot more than
us and by hanging around them a little
bit longer some of their mindsets their
attitudes their beliefs the way they
think seeps in to us to help us become
the best version of ourselves so today
we're going to learn from Gary
Vaynerchuk pulling from his most
motivational clips from 2015 mentor me
Gary and as usual guys as Gary is
talking if we said something that really
resonates with you please leave it down
the comments below
but quotes around it to other people can
be inspired as well enjoy
I hear people say like how do I get into
New York Times or or how do I get that
meeting with that CEO not often times I
just say one is better than zero
the steps it takes to actually get to
the biggest place in the world before
you get a meeting with you know Luxor or
Cuban or Barry Diller or what were you
trying to have a meeting with in the
business world we've got to have a lot
of little meetings that could build up
your penis you always like man you've
been uncoated at an Ellen and the Today
Show and CNN and Fox like how do I get
that and I'm like well I also did a
thousand interviews it feels like on
videos I got one for nineteen or 137
when you're like manners and handlers
are really pissed at me because you're
like why are you spending fifteen
minutes doing these blogs s6 Peters you
know every single day and you're passing
on the summer we're giving you to be on
CNN your time I still even today and as
happy and suppose even more excited to
be on a podcast or video blog that's
only going to reach 100 people because
the whole year about depth versus whip
you want a wide anyone goes deep I want
to people in my community I want you to
ask people that were fans of me and so
even play where I have more leverage
that I did smear four or five six years
ago to get bigger platforms I still live
under the model of one is better than
zero the mean doing use interview to the
process of the work that so many people
are impatient I'm not willing to do are
you will take 10 minutes again 195 use I
am I don't know who asleep walk you've
not gotten exposure net when you have
not made your main just yet when you're
still making the client when you're not
paying attention because nobody else is
the 217 people watch the video I'm
grinding when you're sleeping I did
those 87th and 59th of 137th and 813
views day in and day out day in and day
out day in and day out and continue to
you may make a video on somebody's video
show that has 89 viewers but one of
those 89 viewers may be a producer at
CNN or or might be the CFO of a big
company that you're trying to reach and
so undervaluing just that one view needs
to be the right view but
one view is a humongous we think it's
about having the humility it's about not
saying though even when you've made it
and the one is greater than zero concept
is something I'm proud that I continue
to execute on if you actually love what
you're doing if you actually love it
there is no friction but turn on your
brain the only time I feel like I have
to turn on my brain was when I was six
to 22 years old when I was going through
the [ __ ] education system of America
right that's what I felt like had to
turn it on you know to appease horse
crap that didn't match my reality but
ever since that day when like yay and I
went into like you need to buy this
Pinot Grigio the second that started in
May of 1998 there's never been a day
that I've had to activate it's always on
and I don't mean always on buzzword
marketing it's that I love what I do so
much that there is no friction to turn
it on even when I am landing at two
o'clock in the morning from a flight
that's delayed like the other night and
then going directly into it at 6:30 in
the morning because the fire is so deep
inside you love it so much you know you
don't need that jumpstart Amy asks a
professor once said to me it's better to
be a big fish in a small pond do you
agree
Amy this fat you know I'm going to be
very upfront on this question that's a
good way to bang out the shell that
sounds like a loser professor to me
it's small-time thinking I don't
subscribe to it there's a lot of
practicality in it right there it's a
lot easier to be the most successful
businessman in st. Louis Missouri that
it is to be in the world right so I
understand the thesis but honestly that
to me is very conservative not in my DNA
thinking that could be great advice for
a lot of people who are delirious and
think they're better than they are
though I love to drive through
self-esteem and optimism and I think
early in your life you should absolutely
shoot for the highest stars that you can
I think as life moves on and time moves
on you need to become more practical
you've got bills and kids and all those
kind of things but to start off one's
career in the first 20 years call to
your 40 to be in that thinking I think
that limit the
being so many people who've hedged and
settled in their lives and honestly I'm
not the kind of character that's going
to play in that kind of sphere I'm going
in a different direction it's where it
comes natural to me but it's also
because I think I could be the biggest
and the baddest in any game i play it's
just how I'm wired I think this comes
down to it's probably very good advice
to some and it's probably atrocious
advice to others and this is why I
continue say if I could inject anything
into anybody it would be self awareness
because it would help you answer this
question because for a lot of people
it's probably really solid advice for me
and for many of you watching this it's
crap advice being a dick about it I know
I'm sitting in a room full of number
twos threes and fours there's so many
people in this room that are like going
to be dot like could be dominant
number two threes and fours and I'm
pissed that the narrative now is that we
need to be a number one and have your
company because a lot of people going to
lose or lose money on the table because
that's just the marriage I really do
think you have to audit who you actually
are you can look at like how people roll
and like it creates admire and things of
that nature but it's so damn important
you need to bet on your shrink and don't
give a [ __ ] about what you suck at way
too many people listen we're going to
spend the next 30 40 years of their
lives trying to check the boxes other
things that they're not as good at and
that you're going to waste a load of
time in these two sticks alike your DNA
because the truth is if you want to be
an anomaly you've got to act like one
you know like and so that's it that's
what I got so thanks for having me
action or enthusiasm the truth is my
friend M Squared can I call you that
miss your money
the real answer to that question really
is both the funny thing is I know tons
of people with massive enthusiasm and
they can't execute on the flip side I
know people that can execute aids on all
their papers but without that passion or
bravado or fire they're only able to get
limited return on that investment of
execution so really I'm probably a 60/40
action execution 16 enthusiasm 40 I know
a lot of people might not get that but
the truth is
I'm Way more proud of my execution
skills all this all this charisma hides
what I really am which is a hard core
executors don't forget I executed a
large business before I ever hit the
scene
I was already 30 years old when I
started Wine Library TV and started that
whole process and so I'm a 60/40
execution enthusiasm action I might even
be a 6535 heck as I sit here maybe on
the 70/30 what I would say the hustle is
to me is that when you have passion
around something that you are squeezing
every last bit of the juice out of the
orange right coming Hustle is maximizing
the energy you're putting into somebody
I'm blown away by people saying that
they're hustling and they want to
achieve these great things and then
their actions don't match it's like
saying you really want to lose weight
while eating a big back right so to me
hustle would be putting all your effort
into achieving the goal at hand and for
me that means making every minute count
hiring a full-time assistant who's ever
I mean Friday night didn't happen
because I was hustling like every minute
like if I miss my 15 minutes to tape the
show I've missed my 15 minutes because
there's so much hustle my day there's no
you know there's no like there's no
hanging out there's not only time we're
like if I just do like one joke with you
guys as I'm walking in between meetings
we like to find out to be like a rare
acquaintance situation like like
currents not clean house always putting
it all on the line awesome is waking up
one day the day before you died and
realize when you gave it your all in
terms the parenting of your children the
building of your businesses the lamp
three that you wanted to do whatever you
define it's just you know all-in
emotionally and executional e Imperium
strategy and in that kitchen
my dad Tom B word is bond I've said a
couple times from people that watch me a
lot they know this that when I walked
into my dad's business at 14 let's just
say I was a little bit of a [ __ ]
artist
and you know a lot of the charisma and
the showmanship and the salesmanship
that a lot of you enjoy and I appreciate
that
also comes with being full of crap it's
got a very similar cousin DNA and I'm
glad I got very lucky
let's call it what it is I do not think
I'd be as honorable or as good of a dude
without my dad's correction of you may
come I never forget it
you make a commitment you buy it when I
started buying wine you buy 50 cases no
matter what you take those 50 cases if
you say I'll take 50 cases if the market
changes if it gets an 84 in the Wine
Spectator you take it you eat it you
drink it
your word is bonded because I play the
marathon not the sprint long from
business man that's helped me a lot
because I've kept relationships forever
because sticking to it has mattered
quite a bit I think that I can turn
arrows b15 Jackson hear that when I buy
the debt keeps me motivated know the
real dirty drama be funny Nigerian right
like I love it
plus I'm using for your bill assist in
the flowers look with the pitch appear
when I would only talk about I actually
this is the worst day of my life
that's the whole narrative of the damage
s how lost I am because I hope
oh right and that's one before like bad
alignment here on the car loans like
talk about gonna be but all the time I
will this process I created such a heavy
north are you know it's creating a right
you know keep climbing valve ever we
having to change it
ideally say your works are other
variations of the moon render the clouds
I feel like only having animals are is
leaving a much more honorable lazy
driven not anymore because out hottie
over this big day and a lot of things
going to having that one years it's
giving that critique a unfailing
internality
you know if that person were helping
thirteen years when their ex-wife baby
so I think if imagine that I've waited
for probably what the jet represent into
becomes American added of your waitress
people's with Kickstarter right so my
real plan oh it's 75 I feel going up
there ask everybody help me like effect
enough people with the Meredith
evolution launching in survive we need
I'm a big fan of going all-in and your
strengths and outsourcing we're not
focusing on your weaknesses I think
you've got a pegged right I think the
one thing is sometimes it's obvious
right don't get caught in the obvious
meaning it's obvious to you that you
suck in accounting it's kind of easy
right it's math like I probably also
don't want to or like doing it that's
easy it's the thing that's in the
shadows that's not as obvious there's
something you're doing right now that a
lot of people could do better than you
it's easy when you're an F at it and you
know you need an a but what about the
fact that you might be doing something
right now a tiger somewhere else where
you're a be at it but you could afford
to have somebody be an a at it that's
where people miss mistake so it takes
deep self-awareness you know I'm not a
big believer in like try try try harder
be better at this thing I think it's a
waste of resources energy and happiness
often now if you get off on that kind of
thing like persevering like yourself out
role how you want to roll but for me big
believer I'm betting on all your
strengths and trying to find compliments
to your weaknesses Young Entrepreneur
asks would you ever automate your
position delegate to as many people as
it take and spend 95% of your
I'm fully engaged in family and life
absolutely not
there's young entrepreneur young
entrepreneur let me tell you something
from old entrepreneur which is I love
the process of the work I love the grind
I love the climb you know I love the
idea of getting to buying the Jets more
so than buying the Jets it's the process
to delegate out what I love would defeat
the purpose of course I want to spend as
much time with my family as possible but
that would be lying to my soul if I
didn't do what I want to do and what I
want to do for a living is build
organizations build companies create
commerce be a Salesman be a guidance
counselor HR character social
commentator and put out content I would
suffocate if I couldn't put out the work
that's needed to accomplish the things
that I want the problem young
entrepreneurs especially when you're a
young entrepreneurs people want stuff
right they want the bling bling here
right they want the cool ass kicks they
want the car they want the jet not jets
they want stuff I don't want stuff I
want the sweat and the pain and the
gratitude and the you know happiness
that comes along with the work I want
the work I don't want to stop
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
got you fired out most about this video
it's hard not to be motivated after
watching this one but what was your
favorite clip what did you take from
this that you're then going to
immediately pour into your business your
life leave it down the comments below
super truth to find out I also want to
give a quick shout out to stay czar
Bonilla making so much for picking up a
top of my book your one word and
tweeting that picture out about it as
well I really really really really
appreciate it so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope to
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
Roberto asks what do you feel is a
bigger obstacle to success a lack of
time or lack of capital Roberto this is
a tremendous question I think the
biggest obstacle to success is a lack of
optimism that question in itself is a
problem my friend right you're looking
at two things that are both negative and
guess what both of them are obstacles
when I started winelibrary.com
transformation for my business I had
time I worked my face off every minute
but we don't have a whole lot of money
in our profit Center so it took more
time right it's just the way it is
today I have more money but boy don't I
have time but neither ever ever will be
an excuse for me and so just add illness
through the root of the vaynernation
that's right I want that graphic don't
smile be rock here's the bottom line I
refuse to allow you to get an answer to
that question because both of them are
firmly square in the excuse column and I
have no patience for that there will
always be problems let's talk about a
million other things that are a way to
stop success the health and well-being
of your family members so it takes your
mind away from execution the country you
live in is government and political you
know concepts at these moments I lost
startups in China that I've invested in
that got traction but then people that
were wired into the government decided
to not allow it to happen and then the
startup disappeared not as easy to be an
entrepreneur there it's still a
communist country sorry it just is and
so all these things can be problems
right there's a competitor with a
billion dollars who's also skilled and
punches you in the mouth and knocks you
out in the first round right the world
changing I mean they should be mooing in
obstacles right the media one bad
coverage of you a moment in time you
know what I think about a lot you know I
think about a lot let's get really real
this is why we did this show I always
I'm a human being and I always think
about a moment in time what if I just
say the wrong thing at the wrong time
right what if I call out China for being
a communist country in an episode while
I'm on a rant and somebody's watching
doesn't like the way that tastes and it
takes a
a business opportunity for me in China
and seven years even though I'm not
trying to saying it just things that I
saw what if what if you know what if
what if I look down on my phone while
I'm driving even though I really not
done that and I hit somebody and I kill
them and that becomes the story and they
like forget about the story about what
you think of me I will never recover
from that because I killed somebody
because I needed to check a tweet these
are moments in time so there are so many
things that can keep you from being
successful right the people that you
invested in having something that
happened to them so it slows you down my
friends there are a million reasons why
not but there's one great reason why
which is you've just got to persevere no
matter what it is it's just a way that
it's hard being an entrepreneur it's
hard building a business everybody
thinks it's so easy that there's an
entitlement there's a disaster zing in
China here because my us thing right now
there is an insane generation of 18 to
25 year olds right now that think
they're entitled to having a business
because they saw the social network
movie and everybody decide if you're a
kid and you know what tech is because
you use Instagram early on you're
entitled to actually build a business
building a business is hard and you want
makes it really hard
everything that happens every day of
every moment so you can pick time you
can pick money as the one or two things
that you think stopped you from winning
your game but the truth is there's a
million reasons 99 percent businesses go
out of business for a reason and that
reason is it's hard and so if you're
watching this show I've got a sense of
who you are and you need to start
creating layers and layers and layers
and layers in to be able to get through
because the glamour of being an
entrepreneur the goodness you know you
get 30 computers buy my optimism because
it's my optimism I can't help it it's
just how I roll it's probably one of the
variable 1% reasons why I'm successful
but please don't get it twisted
this is hard every day is hard and if
you don't have the stomach to weather
the storm you will not be successful and
by the way let me throw you a real weird
curveball and that's okay people have to
look themselves in the mirror and
understand that there
two three four five six seven in the
organization that has differences of
being a number one but maybe that's
where your skill set sets maybe that's
how you make your fortunes and happiness
and all the things that you're looking
for and so that question got me going a
little bit Steve because it's under the
context of excuses and I will never make
an excuse everything that's a problem
with me everything I don't achieve
everything that's a problem with
vaynermedia and everything is my fault
and I I should come to that and I
respect that
and I actually think that's the way it
should be and so no excuses amendments